je
j'ai l'impression d'avoir effectivement
vieille de 30 ans en quelques mois la
personne qui est vous parler tu es là
c'est pas la personne que je suis
habituellement je vais très très
énergiques gel voix puissante âge fut
enseignant pendant un problème au fond
de la classe
donc là j'ai le corps pluvieux la fois
plus vite et que le corps de la vous
admiriez merde qui travaille je marche à
deux kilomètres heure cela m'a un peu
manquée par le trouvera du rap et net
alors que normalement même pas 10
on a besoin de beaucoup plus de données
pour avoir ces chiffres là mais d'après
ce qu'on voit dans les études nos
estimations seraient que ça pourrait de
10 à 30% qui auraient des complications
à long terme
ce qu'on fait avec les études à travers
le monde sait au moins jusqu'à six à
sept mois il ya des complications et je
peux vous dire avec les patients qu'on
ne vit les appels qu'on reçoit
il ya des patients à un an pour cette
infection qui ont toujours des séquelles
de la couvée